what does your future look like like
what do you think about the next five
years
10 years i want to be a movie star i
want to be an actor
yeah i want to win oscars i want to do
all that stuff like that that is my plan
and like with that comes modeling so i
want to
do modeling as well but acting is
something that i really like
found like a passion for and like
hopefully i do well in it because i have
no experience in
acting that's the thing like but i'm
very competitive and like i won't
allow myself to be bad at it which is
good yeah so i'm excited
i've been having acting class and
everything so i was just gonna ask you
so you're taking acting classes right
now
i am i actually have acting class in a
few hours and so i'm going to that
i've been doing it a few times a week
i'm getting into it and it's
it's very hard it is very hard and it's
i've learned things
in acting where like i would have never
thought like just watching a movie i'm
like i don't even think of it like that
like i have such a different like
respect now when i watch movies than i
did when i didn't want to be an actor
yeah and watch and it's crazy how
good some people are at acting and how
they can
really make you believe that that's
what's going on you have to be
vulnerable you have to be a sponge you
have to soak in information and so it's
like
i'm very excited but it is a process
it's very hard
do you have like a dream role
that you would want to do like you want
to do tvs you want to just do movies
um my dream i don't know if i have a
dream rule
obviously like like growing up i would
watch like these netflix shows and then
i
i recently became like really i'd watch
them like in my dorm room sometimes when
i was bored
but like he's like rom-coms noah
centennial type movies like i was just
gonna say do you get that
like the comparisons between you and you
remind me so much of him like you look
like him and you guys are both very
like warm nice people oh thank you
yeah no he like so i would watch his
movies
and now he's like a really good friend
of mine and he's become like a mentor to
me and like
we hang out sometimes and he's very down
to earth and so he
i don't know i think it'd be cool to
play like that kind of like heartthrob
kind of role like that would be
i mean that's like my ideal role but
then my acting coach wants me to like
really showcase like what i've learned
and wants me to do like anywhere from
like
being a psychopath to being like a nerd
or like
just in general just like showing that i
can play like be versatile
i'd say my goal for acting like my dream
role is to just be versatile
like i want to be able to do different
things and i think that'd be really cool
you said that noah's been kind of a
mentor to you and i'm just worried
what kind of advice he's given to you
because i've told him
the stuff that i want to do and like
similar to his rules and he's like no
like trust me you have he's like you
have to look for it i can tell by just
talking to you like
he's basically just told me like it's
hard
and you can't get too consumed by the la
lifestyle like you have to keep your
head on straight like
basically the pretty common sense kind
of things where it's like it has like
common sense but it is easy to get
it yeah it really is and so he's just
basically reminding me like you got to
keep your head on straight
you have to do this show up on time like
all all the right things
and so he's very nice and like he's very
like
like a sweet guy and so it's it's cool
talking to him about this stuff because
he goes in like on these movies and it
really is cool seeing like him being an
actor because like these roles that he
plays like he's played some where he's
got to be like
a bit more of like this like douchier
version of himself and i
thought it was just kind of funny seeing
that because he's really just like so
down
really yeah will we ever see you guys
do something together like that would be
so cool
yeah that would be good potentially
maybe teaching me how to act like that'd
be kind of cool i love it
we'll see i mean potentially
you